Brook is with us in Tampa Florida hi
Brooke how are you I was actually
calling I was wondering however you
mentioned we worked a lot in school and
I had questions and more so on the
trying management aspect of it like I'm
24 I have a little bit of student loans
that aren't due yet but now that I
turned one here I'm getting like a lot
more in grants so I probably don't you
know even have to look at them again
until I have to tell them so I won't be
really adding anything to it I'm trying
to work as much as possible but I know
yeah but Japanese likes a time manager
like 24 well the first thing you do is
you budget obviously your time for your
classes and then you budget your time
for your study around your classes and
then you budget work social comes after
that most people if they throw a brick
through their television they find about
30 hours a week and that's pretty
amazing right there I mean people ask me
how I read so many books a year I just
don't watch a lot of TV anymore and I'm
not mad about television I don't think
the devil is in there although we
probably is having a pretty good time
there but it's not like it's something
like that's not like a spiritual thing
it's just a matter of what do I want to
spend my time on it gives me my best
life I'll spend my time on grandbabies
children wife me work reading these are
you know a long time before I spend my
time so just being intentional with your
time you'll be amazed how much time I
mean you know how many time you been
so many people spend two hours a day on
Facebook then you talk about a colossal
freakin waste of time there's one so if
you just stayed off social media
completely or virtually completely and
you turned off your television you can
make a pretty good living with that time
the second thing I would do other than
that is other than getting away from
time wasters and budgeting my time is
your best income production things at
your age while in school when you need
to control your time are typically some
kind of self-employed or straight
commission slash self-employed idea at
24 years old you can make more money
nannying and babysitting you can make 15
20 bucks an hour doing that you can make
more money cleaning people's houses you
can make 25 or 30 dollars an hour doing
that and neither one of these things
require extremes levels of skill I mean
yes you obviously need to know something
about children and it would be good if
you had CPR at the Y you take in the
class and got it certified and so on
right but and you know those those sorts
of things but you can make really good
money and control your time or book the
times that you're willing to do those
things around your classroom time doing
that so do away with the time wasters
intentionally budget your time and look
for self-employed and or straight
commission ideas where when you work you
get paid very well and you control when
you work and work a lot I was selling
real estate in college now that's a very
unusual college activity but I grew up
in a real estate household mom and dad
owned a company when I was growing up so
I got my real estate license three weeks
after I turned eighteen years old and I
worked 40 to 60 hours a week selling
real estate but that means I worked
every weekend but that's when a lot of
real estate people do
they work Saturdays and Sundays Sean
houses they work in the evenings Sean
houses and evenings Saturdays and
Sundays aren't usually when you do
college so it worked out pretty good
that's the kind of stuff I did bro so
hey man thank you for calling we
appreciate you joining this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]